[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
wohin treibt Italien seit heute hat das
Land eine neue Ministerpräsidentin
Georgia Meloni Chefin einer
rechtsradikalen Partei mit
faschistischen Wurzeln mit dem
regierungsgepäck hat sie die Herren
Salvini und Berlusconi die zwei hat
Europa in der Vergangenheit jetzt schon
ausführlich kennenlernen dürfen
Berlusconi prahlte erst kürzlich damit
dass Vladimir Putin ihn zum Geburtstag
20 vodka-flaschen und einen Zitat süßen
Brief geschickt habe Liebesgrüße aus
Moskau die passend
bleibt die Frage wie lange dieses Trio
zusammenbleibt aus Rom Andreas Postel
[Musik]
Georgia Meloni ist am Ziel 100 Jahre
nach Mussolinis Marsch auf Rom übernimmt
die Vorsitzende der Ultra rechten
fratellit Italia mit Neo faschistischen
Wurzeln das Regierungsamt in Italien im
Rekordtempo von nur vier Wochen hat sie
diszipliniert eine neue Regierung des
rechten Lagers geschmiedet im
Quirinalspalast in Rom wird die erste
Ministerpräsidentin Italiens vom
Staatspräsidenten vereidigt den Amtseid
muss sie nicht ablesen
ich schwöre der Republik die Treue zu
halten die Verfassung und die Gesetze zu
beachten und mein Amt ausschließlich im
Interesse der Nation auszuüben
Situation in der neuen Regierung hat
ihre Partei mit neuen Posten die meisten
Minister Rechte leger und konservative
Forza Italia erhielten je 5 in den Tagen
zuvor gab es noch heftigen Streit um die
Kabinettsposten überschattet von Putin
freundlichen Aussagen Silvio Berlusconis
seine Vorzeit Italia wird nun von
Antonio Tajani als neuem Außenminister
und vizeprämie vertreten sein der
ehemalige Präsident des Europaparlaments
möchte für einen verlässlichen Kurs
Italiens stehen
ich möchte meine ganze Erfahrung
einbringen um sicherzustellen dass
Italien alle Hindernisse überwinden kann
die sich ihm in den Weg stellen sowohl
in wirtschaftlicher Hinsicht als auch
leider an den Grenzen der Union mit dem
blutigen ukrainekrieg von dem wir alle
hoffen dass er bald möglichst zu Ende
geht
zweiter regierungsvize wird Matthäus
Salvini von der rechten Liga von dem in
der Vergangenheit eine
russlandfreundliche Haltung bekannt ist
er bekommt von Meloni nicht das
prestigeträchtige Innenministerium
sondern das Ministerium für Verkehr und
Infrastruktur auch so wird von Italien
zukünftig eine härtere
antimigrationspolitik erwartet außerdem
hat das rechte Regierungsbündnis ihrer
Wählerschaft eine Land order Politik
versprochen nach dem Motto Italien
zuerst
sie haben eine sehr wütende Wählerschaft
die den Institutionen sehr feindlich
gegenübersteht aber es sind auch
wohlhabende Leute die Geschäfte und
wirtschaftliche Unternehmen haben mit
anderen Worten keine revolutionäre
sondern bürgerliche Leute ohne Interesse
ihr Land in die Luft zu jagen
große Sorgen bereitet in Europa melonis
Haltung zur EU trotz ihrer jüngsten
Erklärungen Italien werde voll und ganz
Teil Europas und der NATO bleiben morgen
wird die 45-Jährige von Mario Draghi
Amtsgeschäfte übernehmen und in Rom mit
dem regieren beginnen
dass ich die Kommunistische Partei
Chinas immer noch so nennt obwohl das
Regime wirtschaftlich eher archiatischen
Raubtierkapitalismus praktiziert gehört
ja auch zu den Eigentümlichkeiten dieses
Systems in dem allerdings nach wie vor
gilt die Partei und ihre Kader stehen
über alle heute endete ihr großer
Kongress in Peking und da hat sich eine
höchst eigenartige Szene abgespielt
der ehemalige Staats- und
parteichefudium Vorgänger des aktuellen
Diktators wird von Podium geholt und aus
dem Saal gebracht sichtlich gegen seinen
will was den Vorfall noch bizarrer macht
dass er von internationalen Medien
gefilmt werden konnte die meiste Zeit
tagt der Kongress nämlich ohne Kameras
Steiner in Peking wie erklärt man sich
in China diese Szene
so wie wir diesen Parteitag seit einer
Woche hier in Peking erleben ist es
schwer vorstellbar dass das ein Versehen
gewesen sein soll das ist so ein streng
durchorganisiertes Ritual das ja nichts
zufällig passiert vieles deutet darauf
hin dass es eine Machtdemonstration von
Chitin pink war das würde das Bild
passen dass er mit seiner historischen
dritten Amtszeit eine neue Ära einläuten
will es wird hier auf jeden Fall
verstanden als Signal dass die Strömung
für die rutschentao steht nicht mehr
gewünscht ist also liberalere Ideen auch
in Wirtschaftsfragen und einen
kollektiven Führungsstil in einem Partei
in einer Parteiführung das ist vorbei
hier den Ping hat die Partei umgebaut
und alle Macht auf sich konzentriert und
wenn er morgen sein neues
Führungsgremium vorstellt dann wird da
wahrscheinlich auch kein Vertreter
dieser Strömung dabei sein und die
vorherige Generation die hat er heute
vor den Augen der Delegierten und der
Presse abführen lassen
Dankeschön Miriam für diese Einschätzung
aus Peking
und dann blicken wir in die Ukraine
welche Kriegsstrategie die Russen dort
jetzt verfolgen ist offensichtlich da
sie auf dem Schlachtfeld nicht gewinnen
können versuchen sie den Willen der
Zivilbevölkerung zu brechen die Angriffe
mit Drohnen und Raketen auf Großstädte
sollen die Menschen zum einen
terrorisieren zugleich wird aus der Luft
auf lebensnotwendige Infrastruktur
gezielt Stromnetze Kraftwerke 40% der
Energieinfrastruktur sollen bereits
schwer beschädigt sein
hofft dass ohne Strom und Heizung im
Winter hunderttausende flüchten werden
was dann wiederum in Aufnahmeländern wie
Deutschland von seiner fünften Kolonne
ausgenutzt werden könnte um Stimmung zu
machen
daran berichtet wie die Menschen in Kiew
versuchen dem Druck stand zu halten
jede Stufe bringt sie näher nach Hause
und in die Dunkelheit es ist das erste
Mal dass in ihrer Wohnung der Strom
abgeschaltet wurde in nessa ist
Grafikdesignerin lebt im mondänen
Zentrum von Kiew gearbeitet hatte
27-Jährige immer von zu Hause aus wann
und wie lange sie wollte jetzt muss sie
ihr Leben an die Stromabschaltung
anpassen
also ich sehe kein Problem wenn der
Strom für ein paar Stunden abgeschaltet
wird geht das Licht aus für den Fall
haben wir Kerzen
es klingt naiv doch Inessa rettete zu
Beginn des Krieges ihre Eltern aus
mariopol für sie ist kein Strom kein
Problem mehr
seit jasma-app gebe die Adresse ein und
da ist der Plan dieser Wochenplan zeigt
jedem wann und wo Strom in der Ukraine
fehlen wird auf die Minute und
Hausnummer genau
umgesetzt wird dies von den
Stromversorgern in der Vorstandsetage
sind sie alarmiert Dimitri fürchtet ein
Systemabsturz deshalb wird im ganzen
Land gestaffelt und gezielt der Strom
für einige Stunden abgeschaltet wenn die
Energieversorger nicht den Verbrauch und
die Produktion angleichen dann könnte
dies zu einem Ausfall des Stromsystems
führen zu einem totalen Stromausfall
um das zu vermeiden wird gewartet und
repariert an dieser Kiefer
Verteilerstation hängen 3000 Haushalte
nur wenn sie funktioniert können
einzelne Straßen kontrolliert vom Netz
genommen werden allein DiTech betreibt
tausende im ganzen Land es ist ein
Wettlauf ukrainische Elektriker gegen
russische Luftangriffe
man sagt sie sind da wo wir sein müssen
wir verteidigen unsere Front im
energiekrieg wir werden bis zum Ende
kämpfen
sieben Mitarbeiter wurden an ihrem
Arbeitsplatz getötet durch russische
Luftangriffe Kraftwerke müssen immer not
besetzt sein selbst bei Luftalarm
diesen Dienstag haben die Russen 1
unserer Kraftwerke mit vier Raketen
beschossen schwere Waffen wurden gegen
zivile Infrastruktur eingesetzt und
haben schweren Schaden verursacht es
braucht Zeit zum Reparieren vor allem
benötigen wir Ersatzteile und die sind
individuell gefertigt man kann sie nicht
im Supermarkt kaufen
wie ernst das um das ukrainische
Stromnetz steht darüber täuscht in den
Kiefer Restaurants das Kerzenlicht
hinweg
und mit den Energieproblemen hier in
Deutschland geht es jetzt bei dir weiter
Heinz ja in der Diskussion über einen
Start der gaspreisbremse bereits zum
ersten Januar will Bundeskanzler Scholz
ausloten was machbar ist und dazu mit
den Energieversorgern beraten nach einem
Treffen mit Handwerkern in München sagte
Scholz es werde nur in einem großen
Schulterschluss in Deutschland gelingen
den organisiere man gerade um die Fragen
zu diskutieren wie das gehe
angesichts der Energiekrise und der
hohen Preise gab es heute in mehreren
deutschen Städten Demonstrationen für
soziale Sicherheit und für eine
schnellere Energiewende aufgerufen zu
den Aktionen mit mehreren tausend
Teilnehmern hatte das Bündnis
solidarische Herbst ein Zusammenschluss
von Gewerkschaften sozial und
Umweltverbänden eine der Forderungen
soziales und Klimaschutz dürften nicht
gegeneinander ausgespielt werden
im Rennen um die Nachfolge der
britischen Premierministerin Trust gibt
es offenbar einen Favoriten der frühere
Finanzminister Regie sunak jetzt ist
durchgesickert dass ihr wohl die
notwendige Unterstützung von 100
konservativen Abgeordneten hat
exponiert Johnson kam heute früher aus
dem Urlaub zurück er hat unter den
Abgeordneten immer noch viele
Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützer
eine sportkletterin die plötzlich
weltberühmt geworden ist Elenas rikabi
wird in Iran als Helden verehrt seit sie
bei einem Wettkampf im Ausland ohne
hit-job aufgetreten war zu ihrer
öffentlichen Entschuldigung danach wurde
sie laut einem BBC-Bericht gezwungen das
Regime habe gedroht ihrer Familie zu
schaden ihren Eltern und ihrem Bruder
sie selbst soll sich jetzt den
Hausarrest befinden auf ihrem
instagram-account bedankte sie sich
heute für Unterstützung und Anteilnahme
auch aus dem Ausland
in Berlin ging heute 10.000 Menschen auf
die Straße um ihre Solidarität zu zeigen
mit der Protestbewegung in Iran Carsten
Behrendt und Lisa Jandy berichten
ein Lied für die Freiheit
Hymne des Protests
sie singen es im Iran und heute in
Berlin 80.000 sind gekommen angereist
aus ganz Europa
ich bin aus Dänemark als Stimme des Iran
ich komme aus Norwegen ein weiter Weg
aber das muss sein für das iranische
Volk zerbricht uns
allen dass ich hart und großes Herz dann
muss man jetzt einfach etwas es ist die
bislang größte Demo in Europa für
Freiheit in Iran aufgerufen hat Hamid
ismaelion Zahnarzt und Autor aus Kanada
in unseren Träumen weht der Wind der
Freiheit durch das Haar der Frauen
vor knapp drei Jahren wurden seine Frau
und Tochter getötet in einer
Passagiermaschine fälschlicherweise
abgeschossen vom iranischen Militär
seitdem kämpft er gegen das Regie
Berlin ist für alle ein symbolischer Ort
hier wurde die Mauer eingerissen und wir
hoffen dass auch die Mauern im Iran
fallen werden und die Menschen dem
Berliner Beispiel folgen werden
sanas azimi pur hat die Demo mit
organisiert sie hat Freunde und Familie
im Iran doch die Kommunikation wird
wegen Internetsperren immer schwieriger
seit Wochen engagiert sie sich mit
anderen Iranerinnen und Iranern um den
Protest in ihrer Heimat zu unterstützen
wir wollen nicht ihr Stimme sein weil
wir sind hier und wir sind nicht sicher
und da sind wir auch bewusst was für
Privilegien wir haben ich glaube wichtig
ist nur ihre Stimme zu verstärken
erstmal ein Zeichen zu setzen und das
unser Wut und unser Schmerz halt viel
viel größer ist als die amerikanische
Regierung die Demo heute soll auch ein
Weckruf sein für die Europäische Union
und die Bundesregierung die bislang
beschlossenen Sanktionen gehen ihm nicht
weit genug
[Applaus]
wir fordern die deutsche Politik dass
die jegliche diplomatische und
politische Beziehungen mit den
terroristischen Regime von Iran
aufbrechen
80.000 in Berlin
80.000 stimmen
für die Freiheit
[Musik]
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter Heinz
in Auckland sind die Gruppen für die
Frauenfußball WM im kommenden Sommer in
Australien und Neuseeland ausgelost
worden das deutsche Team trifft in
Gruppe H auf Kolumbien Südkorea und
WM-Neuling Marokko
die Lottozahlen dieses samstags sie
lauten wie immer ohne Gewähr
1.4 14 24 31 46 Superzahl 1 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im zdf-text auf Seite
die Wetteraussichten morgen gibt es nach
Nebelauflösung einen Mix aus Sonne und
Wolken am Nachmittag kommen im Westen
Schauer dazu gegen Abend auch Gewitter
die Temperatur steigt auf Werte von 16
bis 24 Grad am Montag regnet es vor
allem im Süden kräftig am Dienstag und
Mittwoch gibt es nur selten Schauer und
die Sonne scheint häufig es bleibt mit
Höchstwerten zwischen 14 und 23 Grad
sehr mild
das war es von uns an diesem
Samstagabend gleich geht's zum
Sportstudio weiter und die nächste
heute-express gibt es dann um 0.25 etwa
und uns morgen wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]